well out the gate I'm going to give this
movie props because it stresses beyond
the shadow of a doubt that me and a
gentleman in a suit is cool let's face
it it is so thank you movie the intern
the interns that movie you don't
remember you right now you're like the
intern what movie is s at Anne Hathaway
movie where Robert De Niro's like the
old senior citizen intern yeah that one
so like I just said the intern stars
Anne Hathaway and Robert De Niro and
Hathaway plays a CEO of this online
startup company she's a young real get
it done kind of CEO she likes to do
everything herself but that's created
quite a workload for her Robert De
Niro's a 70 year old guy he's retired if
there's one thing we know is that
retirement kills old people if you
retire you got to find something to do
and Anne Hathaway's company started this
new program where they're gonna hire
senior citizens as intern now one of the
things I absolutely loved about this
movie is Robert De Niro
can we just say Robert De Niro in the
intern is what dudes aspire to be like
when they are seven day it is classy
he's sharp he has all the right things
to say he's charming he's optimistic as
one of the things I loved about this guy
is that he is infectiously optimistic to
be the shittiest day ever you're going
to the dentist while eating spiders not
a good day scratch that
worst day go into the dentist while
eating mushrooms Robert De Niro can walk
in the room you're like you know what I
think if we're gonna get through this
but he's not obnoxious about it he's not
like Emma Stone in that Aloha movie no
he's just real about it I love him in
this movie this is what my favorite
Robert De Niro roles I've seen in quite
a long time probably big softy but I
like it when people who become famous
and are more well known for playing
mobster murderers play really awesome
older dudes I thought he had good
contrast with Anne Hathaway also
sometimes Anne Hathaway's character I
was like you're being weird you're doing
that thing where you're kind of a head
case but she's young and the movie
stresses she does have a lot to learn
about life that's why Robert De Niro's
here so it made sense but sometimes just
wanna be like don't do that I love the
fact that the intern in this movie is an
older guy hypothetical looking-glass
situation we're looking into another
dimension this movie comes out it's
actually a young dude you know exactly
how this is gonna play out this is going
to be a rom-com some romantic comedy
were the CEOs totally burdened and then
she meets this younger intern and they
they're gonna form a relationship
they're gonna have a romance phooey haha
this movie doesn't even humor that at
all
Robert De Niro is old enough to be her
grandfather's never a situation it's not
like she gets so trashed she tries to
kiss him he's like I'm old enough to be
her grandfather and said okay we just
won't talk about that then had to
address it for the audience because the
audience would expect that no it's
nowhere in this movie nowhere is there a
romantic relationship between these two
it was a friendship in that it felt much
more organic and real if I have gripes
that I don't know what it is
lightly movies just haven't hit their
Goldilocks zone they haven't hit the
runtime where it's just right not too
long not too short just right this movie
feels a little long and I've said that
so much I have to illustrate what it is
when a movie has branching arcs in the
movie that really don't contribute much
to the plot or the characters and you
can clearly go all right if that was
removed with the movie suffer at all no
boom he just shaved about ten minutes
right there this movie has a couple
situations like that really like that
scene really didn't offer much or that
arc didn't offer much that branch didn't
offer much could have been taken out
could it trim the time in the movie but
that doesn't really change the fact that
you walk out of this movie with the
feels you know like the thing that I
said so I was like so how'd you like it
I was like everybody's cute it was a
cute movie I liked seeing the friendship
between this CEO and this intern who
probably should be the CEO but he's like
I'm the intern I don't have an interest
in being a CEO in the end guys the
intern isn't some groundbreaking movie
it's not like a movie working
oh my god I've never seen anything like
it but Robert DeNiro was great in the
movie you're gonna love him and Hathaway
was good and she worked well with Robert
De Niro in contrast feel like the movie
could have been trimmed down but in the
end if your parents are looking for a
solid date night movie the intern
because the intern is a good time no
alcohol required alright guys so the
intern have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
Robert De Niro movie of all time
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more